so the first thing we're going to look
at is how to make characters and robots
really interactive and that means that
there might not be a puppeteer in the
background actually choosing what
behaviors the character would do but
instead it would really be measuring and
responding to the audience and to the
children in the audience in particular
the reason I'm excited about the lab is
because the entertainment industry as a
whole has basically not funded any
research in academia and so this is a
real opportunity to change that and
Disney's making a strong statement here
that they want to change that they want
a team with people in academia and they
think that that research that results
from that will be really valuable to
them in their business as well as to the
field making progress in the field as a
whole
you